die Mission vorwärts nimmt Fahrt auf bei
den österreichischen Luftstreitkräften
bleibt nahezu kein Stein auf dem anderen
mit dem neuen Leonardo AW 169 wird
dieser Tage nicht nur die tausendste
Flugstunde gefeiert mit ihm beginnt im
Bundesheer ein neues Helikopter
Zeitalter wir haben derzeit fünf
hubschraubersysteme bereits im Dienst
der österreichischen luftstadkräfte und
wir hören jetzt endlich einmal auf mit
unserer schmetterlingsammlung im Bereich
der Hubschrauber sonder wir gehen auf
ein zweiflottensystem was natürlich den
Betrieb und die Logistik wesentlich
vereinfacht und die beiden
hubschraubermodelle der Zukunft sind der
bereits bestens eingeführte Blackhawk
und der neue AW 169 von dem 12 Maschinen
am Standort eigen im enstal zum Einsatz
kommen und die weiteren anderen
Maschinen werden in langen Lebern
eingesetzt und stationiert werden
einerseits in der Schule und
andererseits auch den Ersatz der
altbewerten oh58 Kova Baujahr 1970 damit
trennt sich das bundeser mittelfristig
von dero 3 dem oh58 kaiova und der
Augusta Bell
ab212 und das wiederum bedeutet dass in
den Standort eigen im enstal
entsprechend investiert wird und hier
wird auch die eigene typenwerft sein
für für die gesamte Staffel die hier
beschafft wird das heißt es sind
Investitionen not notwendig
beträchtliche Investitionen die in etwa
47 Millionen Euro auch ausmachen werden
wenn man in der Vergangenheit so
zurückschaut Herr Bürgermeister all
diejenigen Landesrat die da in der
Gegend sind so viele Diskussionen die
das waren über diesen Standort die sind
damit nicht nur weg sondern wir setzen
damit ein Zeichen für eine massive
Aufwertung auch dieses stand dieses
Standortes ich glaube das ist auch
dringend notwendig am Ende wird es 36 AW
169 und 12 blackhaw Helikopter geben bei
letzteren steht eine fristige
aufstoppung auf bis zu 24 Stück im
Raum